Everything i did i did for the rebellion
rogue one in many ways it's a film that
connected new audiences with the oldest fans
it was a bittersweet feeling you know in the
premiere knowing that it was just one film
but then magic happens right as you can see
we're getting ready we're building stages we're
rehearsing we're training we're trying costumes
we're doing everything to make sure we do the
best show i'm really excited having the chance
to explore cassian it's really fun to go on a set
that is emulating something you like so much the
enormity of this is like doing a big feature film
it's very cinematic for me that's where the
excitement is 12 episodes 12 scripts over
200 named cast members over 6 000 crowd people a
lot of creatures that come in from the creature
department we treat this exactly like you would
have with a film there is no difference in our
approach every creature and droid that we've been
building has the same care level of attention
to detail as the previous films it's huge it's
brilliant but also it's wonderfully challenging
there's tons of possibilities to explore
it is the building of a revolution
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this is
going to be my star wars rogue one prequel
trailer video i haven't really talked about
this series yet but i will be doing episode
videos for when it releases it'll be 12 episodes
if you can believe that they're finally actually
doing way more episodes per season of these
disney plus shows i'll explain what's going
on with the characters like what's going on with
darth vader during this period because obviously
we have hayden christensen coming back as
darth vader in the obi-wan kenobi series
that's going to be said before this i'll explain
what the timeline is and when all the star wars
episodes during 2021 are going to be released
and which episodes those will be so if you're
new to the channel be sure to subscribe to get
everything i know everybody just wants to know
when is the mandalorian season 3 episode's going
to start releasing but just starting with the
trailer footage and explaining what's happening
at this part of the timeline and how everything
is connected so this picks up five years before
the events of the rogue one movie so most of the
characters are all still alive most of them from
the movie will be starring on the tv show some of
them they haven't quite confirmed yet but diego
luna's character is the main character that's why
it's called star wars andor because he's cassian
andor the genre that they're doing with the show
is basically spy thriller it's all about the
formative years of the rebellion so i know there's
a big question about ahsoka tano cameoing because
she was there for the birth of the rebellion
mando from the mandalorian the din jarn character
was also very active during this period he was
much younger but he was very active for those of
you that really liked bill bird's character he
was also very active in the empire during this
period pretty much anybody from the mandalorian
series you've seen because that only takes place
about eight or nine years after the events of a
new hope so even moff gideon giancarlo esposito's
character would be in his 30s during the events
of this series and during that period he was just
a regular officer in the imperial security bureau
that was the branch of the empire that was
operating the base on scarif that they went to
infiltrate to steal the death star plans hopefully
they'll finally explain what the black saber
easter egg was and not to be confused with the
dark saber which is a completely different thing
but another really good example is this is also
probably around the period of the mandalorians
great purge so bokeh tan would probably still
be ruling over the mandalorians during this
period with the darksaber so because they have
12 episodes to tell their story hopefully we
will see some easter eggs and connections to
those other series it's also about five years
or so after the events of what's going to be
happening in the obi-wan kenobi series which
we know hayden christensen is coming back for
as both darth vader and for anakin skywalker
stuff for flashbacks obviously the events of this
series will also probably overlap a little bit
maybe with patty jenkins rogue squadron movie
just because that sounds like it's going to
be taking place during the original trilogy
era around the time of the rogue one movie
alan tudyk is coming back as k2so i'm so happy
about that because he was amazing as that droid
he's taking us through it and there's a fresh one
if you mouth off again we'll take them from here
pretty much all the major empire characters were
around during this period and very active like
darth vader the emperor the inquisitors all still
very very active sure would be nice if they gave
the mandalorian 12 episodes per season but they
do have all the spin-off series and the story
overlaps between all those different shows that
they're doing so technically they get like 20
episodes per cycle they didn't say exactly how
much they plan on using darth vader during the
series but my assumption just based on the big
luke skywalker mandalorian season 2 finale twist
is that when darth vader shows up outside of the
obi-wan kenobi series he'll just be full armor
darth vader with james earl jones doing the voice
it won't be hayden christensen unless it's the
ahsoka tano series which is kind of a different
situation because i think we're all just hoping to
have some ahsoka anakin skywalker scenes and there
are only a couple ways you can do that you either
do flashbacks with rosario dawson to when he
was still alive or you do force ghost anakin and
present day but you kind of have to think of this
series as a live-action version of the star wars
rebels animated series but that'd be a really easy
way to do a live-action version of kanan jarrus
who died during star wars rebels before the events
of the rogue one movie darth maul is also very
much alive during this period too so he could also
be involved through the crime syndicates that was
mainly what he was doing around that period
when he wasn't with ezra bridger trying to
turn him to the dark side of the force and it's
also the period of time where ahsoka tano had
that reunion fight with darth vader at the sith
temple even though if they ever decided to try
and do a live-action version of that they would
probably save it for the ahsoka tano series and
it would be like a flashback memory that she's
having that is probably one of the best star wars
scenes of all time not just animated scenes but
anything from the live-action movies as well it
was so mind-blowing how good a job they did with
that some of the twists during this fight scene
also kind of explain why they would want to go
through the trouble of paying the extra money to
get hayden christensen to come back and play darth
vader because most of the time he's wearing the
mask and he sounds like james earl jones so why
would you need to put hayden christensen in the
suit to do that well you do that so that you can
have a darth vader scene that turns into an anakin
skywalker scene when his mask gets broken and you
see anakin underneath the armor when this happens
his speech also goes back to anakin's speech it's
not being amplified anymore so he sounds like
hayden christensen anakin when this is happening
i won't leave you not this time then you will die
i know everyone just wants to see darth vader
come back and wreck the hell out of everyone
the cool thing about that darth vader scene
is they actually basically gave luke skywalker
his own version of a hallway scene just like the
rogue one scene like father like sun and speaking
of really big original trilogy character cameos
during this rogue one prequel series the other
biggest character that we haven't really talked
about in a while is princess leia but you have
to keep in mind that the rogue one prequel
series picks up five years before the events
of the movie and she's only 19 during a new hope
so she'd be like 13 14 years old when the rogue
one prequel series picks up so they would have
to cast like a completely different actress to
play that character and i don't think that they
want to do that right away you guys can let me
know in the comments do you think that they should
just stay away from a young version of leia or do
you want to see her have a luke skywalker kind
of cameo in the background they also announced
stellen skarsgard is going to be playing one
of the main imperial villain characters they
didn't say which character he's playing or if
he's playing a major original trilogy character
genevieve o'reilly is coming back as mon mothma
she's the one that played young mon mothma
during revenge of the sith and then came back
to play her again during the rogue one movie
then the only other actors that they've announced
are denise goff fiona shaw and adria orona but
they didn't say who they're playing just in terms
of how far they're going to take this and how big
the easter eggs are going to be just look at the
mandalorian episodes and use that as a template
if they're going for easter eggs that big i feel
like they're going to do the same thing during the
rogue one prequel series but here's the lineup for
2021 star wars episodes we're going to get three
different star wars tv shows during 2021 the first
one that's supposed to drop i believe is the bad
batch that's the brand new animated series set
right after the clone wars from dave filoni so
it's all him and it's going to feel very much like
the clone wars but it's set during the rise of the
empire there's the star wars visions tv show which
is supposed to come a little bit later in the year
that's the anthology series that's going to be
a series of directors doing different episodes
about totally different things but if you heard
about an anime star wars series this is the one
i don't know how many episodes it's going to be
then thankfully they've already confirmed that
the mandalorian spin-off the book of boba fett
episodes will start airing the week of christmas
next year they haven't absolutely confirmed
how many episodes they're supposed to be but i
believe it's between four and six episodes just
a little bit less than the mandalorian seasons
so that'll run into january february and
then right after that at the beginning of
2021 they'll start doing the mandalorian season
three episodes probably at least by march it just
depends on when the boba fett finale happens but
obviously mingnas character and tamura morrison's
boba fett character are the main characters
they haven't announced which other characters
are going to show up but it's going to be set
around tatooine and it's mostly going to follow
the underworld of the star wars universe the
scum and villainy of the galaxy pedro pascal did
say that he expects to cameo as mando on all the
other spin-offs so we might see mando on the boba
fett series as well as other characters from the
mandalorian season 2 like Bo Katan and the other
mandalorians but hopefully that explains what's
happening with star wars in the next year or so
of course i'll be doing episode videos for
all those shows so as long as you have alerts
enabled for my channel you should see all
those videos when i post them but let me
know which of the new series you're most hyped
up about and who else you want to see show up
on the rogue one prequel series everyone click
here for my brand new mandalorian season 3
luke skywalker in grogu jedi training video and
click here for all my mandalorian episode videos
thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe merry christmas!